So as I mentioned, this is a plugin, therefore it does need to be enabled.
This is not enabled by default, and therefore you should go to your edit plugins section
and make sure that you've turned smart objects on if you want to replicate any of this functionality.
This will already be enabled in the test project.
There's an example scene which we'll go to in a little bit.
So it's already enabled there if you're using that,
but if you're trying to implement this on your own, just be aware it's a distinct plugin that you would need to enable.
So what even are smart objects?
Essentially, smart objects are there to solve a problem or an implementation that you may have,
if you've worked in games that utilize AI,
it's quite likely that you've implemented something like this yourself already,
and you see a lot of interactions like it in any kind of game that might have behaviors
that are numerous that can be performed by actors,
and you wouldn't necessarily want the actor to know all of the things they can possibly do when they do it.
So take for example, I don't know for a fact that they do this by the way,
but take for an example an NPC in Assassin's Creed, right?
They walk around and they do things and occasionally they'll go up and sit down on the bench
and they can probably do things like leaning against a wall,
they can do things like, I don't know, shopping at a cart.
I don't exactly know all the things that AIs do in Assassin's Creed,
but I know that sitting on the bench is a thing they do.
So it might not make sense for us to code all of that logic into the AI itself,
that it knows it can do these thousand different actions.
It kind of makes more sense that we bake that functionality into the object that is being interacted with,
and then anything can interact with it.
We don't need to code this for the 20 different kinds of AIs that can use these things.
All we do is kind of tie the things that are actually tightly related together.
So we have the object that is interacted with,
that is the thing that is responsible for how do you interact with me,
here are the steps that you go through.
And all the AI needs to know is that these things exist in the world,
I can perform these interactions,
there's maybe some additional querying they can do to be like, which action should I choose?
But once they get to that action, it is then the action that tells them how to engage with it.
And at the same time, this idea that, you know,
we don't want two NPCs trying to perform the same action at the same time,
because, you know, if it's something like leaning against a wall or sitting on a bench,
there's only a certain amount of space on that bench,
the two NPCs can't lean against the same wall and it would look silly if they did.
So it's quite likely that if you again,
if you've worked with AI, you've already implemented a system a little bit like this.
I certainly have done myself in previous games,
smart objects didn't exist at that time,
but I totally would have used them if they had.
But essentially smart objects is a plugin that implements this in a kind of nice editor friendly way
with a bit of optimization on top.
So these smart objects are essentially objects that AIs and players can interact with.
And they, like I said,
the object itself contains all of the information required to actually handle the interaction.
All of these interactions are grouped together into a global database
that is then accessible and queryable by anyone who's interested,
and also that these objects utilize partitioning logic
so they can be queried at runtime in a more kind of performant way.
So you're not, you can kind of ignore interactions that are two kilometers away
and focus just on the, just for performance reasons
and also just for kind of logic reasons,
you can be focused a little bit more on the things that are closer to you,
as well as this idea of reservations so that, you know,
we don't have a situation where two actors are traversing, you know,
over 20 meters to both get to the same melon to pick up
and then only at that point do they realize,
oh, this other guy was going to pick up the melon and therefore I can't.
So the five types that we should be aware of when we're,
what are the kind of five fundamental types of be aware of with a smart object system
is the subsystem, smart object collections,
the component, definitions, and then behavior definitions.
We're going to talk a little bit more about each of those.
The smart object subsystem,
if you're already familiar with unreal subsystems,
this is, you can kind of imagine a little bit what this is.
This is essentially the kind of primary point of interaction.
It's a single entry point.
It's only instantiated on servers and multiplayer games
as we've already spoken about with a lot of AI stuff.
Really AI is handled by the server
because it is the server that has authoritative state
that should be responsible for decision making.
Again, the pawns, the things that the other clients would see
are really just there to parrot out the behavior that the server is deciding.
And it's the smart object subsystem
that really couples all of this stuff together.
The smart object subsystem is our entry point
full of our queries and logic
for anyone outside of the actual system itself.
They would query in through the subsystem.
So the subsystem is the kind of like thing
that exposes all of this functionality to other agents, actors, players.
It's also the subsystem that's responsible
for keeping track of all of our smart objects
that are actually in our level.
And yeah, it's automatically created in level
and only one of these would exist at any given time.
So that's a kind of normal thing for a lot of subsystems.
The vast, if you're familiar with unreal subsystems,
you would kind of know these things
are kind of automatically created for us,
they're automatically cleaned up for us.
And for the majority of types, there will only ever be one.
The only one that's contrary to that I can think of
is a local player subsystem, which this isn't.
Yeah, so then we've got the smart object collection.
This is, again, only one of these exists per level.
And this is essentially just a list
of all the smart object components associated with the level.
And it's used to create the instance of those smart objects at runtime.
So, you know, the components linked to the collection,
the collection makes the appropriate smart objects
for those components.
And it's essentially just a place to gather all these things together.
The smart object component is a component
that can be added to any actor.
And it's the component itself that stores the information
about what kind of smart object is this.
And then this component would then get registered
with the smart object collection,
which will create the appropriate smart objects for it.
The actor containing the smart object component
can be loaded and unloaded at runtime.
You know, they're kind of in a large world.
This might happen through world partitioning
or through streaming those levels in and out.
And this isn't a problem.
The system accounts for these things.
And, yeah, if the actor containing the smart object component
is spawned at runtime,
then it's not going to remain in memory once it's unloaded.
So this is more about those kind of permanent fixtures within the level.
If it's spawned in and out at runtime,
then that's not going to have that same level of persistence
within the system because, you know,
that's the kind of nature of these runtime things.
That's then your responsibility to know
how long that's meant to stay around for.
The kind of overall system is really meant for things
that are more like fixtures in the world.
And the more temporary things are things
that you would kind of have to manage independently.
So smart object definition is actually the kind of,
the key object that groups together this behavior.
This is the kind of, well, definition,
don't use the word to define the word,
but it's, yeah, the immutable data that defines this thing.
So this isn't manipulated at runtime.
It simply exposes what does this smart object look like
at a kind of editor level, at a kind of immutable way.
That might be these actions as part of this object definition
is these actions are available.
They're at these locations, at these rotations.
They have particular tags and markup and all of these,
a single definition can contain multiple slots
and it's the slots that agents would choose
to interact with.
So again, going back to like a bench
that might be a smart object
and then that bench might have multiple slots
for every place that you could sit on that bench.
And this is kind of like a static representation
of what this bench interaction would look like.
And then you can drop multiple of those around the world
through a smart object component,
through an actor utilizing that smart object component
and to then have several benches throughout your level.
But the idea of a bench,
the fact that there are three, four, whatever seats
at these separations with these rotations
and these tags on them,
none of that is stuff that is necessarily
going to change at runtime.
So the smart object definition
is this kind of like static editor level definition
of how this thing can be interacted with.
And then the behavior definition
is the thing that occurs essentially each slot.
This is a little bit like our task.
So this is the thing that actually gets performed.
The smart object definition groups these things together,
defines them by slots
and these slots can have behaviors linked to them
and it's behaviors themselves
that are the things that the agents would do.
So the AI agent, player agent or whatever,
this is the kind of functionality that they will perform
whether that's playing animations,
whether it's playing sounds,
whether that's moving to particular locations,
whatever that needs to be,
that this is the actual thing
that would contain the logic
for doing those interactions.
There are a couple of pre-existing examples.
So we've got a gameplay behavior.
So this is for any kind of poem or actor to perform.
Player behavior is specifically built for player characters
and then mass entity,
we'll talk about mass in a little bit,
but this is a behavior that makes use of,
it can basically a smart object interaction definition
that can interact with smart entities
rather than usual kind of gameplay behaviors.
Again, we'll touch on mass entity in a little bit.
So that's just kind of a brief summary
of all of the types.
I'll actually just quickly demonstrate this functionality.
So if you open up the project,
you'll see that it's actually,
we've got our own little example of that.
This is essentially a re-implementation
of the Unreal documentation.
So if you've already been through that,
you'll see that a lot of this is relatively similar.
So if you go to just Unreal's
getting started with smart objects
or smart object quick start,
you'll end up inventing something
a little bit similar to this.
So you don't need to do both of those things,
but this adds just a little bit
of extra functionality on top
that I thought was kind of pertinent.
So one of the things that they don't really highlight
is the kind of benefits and meanings
of this reservation system.
So just to kind of quickly talk through
the various things that we've got here,
we've got the actual smart object itself.
So we've got this smart object definition.
This, like we said,
is the thing that represents
the kind of static editor level data
for what are the different available options
when this smart objects exists in world,
how can it be interacted with in what different places
or what different rotations
and what behaviors are linked to each of these things?
So in this case, we just have a single slot
and it's got this particular behavior that we've put on it
and we've just dropped a couple of actors
utilizing that component,
utilizing that slot into the world.
So that's just this actor here
and as you can see, this is just called play montage
because that's really what the behavior is doing
and you can see we use the smart object component.
In that smart object component,
we've plugged in that smart object definition.
So again, you can see these kind of relationships
all linking up.
The smart object definition implements the behaviors.
The component says what definition should it be using
and then the actor that uses that component,
we've dragged several of those actors around
to essentially drop several of these behaviors
around our world.
So the extra kind of, and then just on top of that,
so again, we've got the definition,
we've got the actual behaviors
that those definitions are doing
and then we've got a behavior tree
that actually just utilizes some of this behavior.
So you'll notice when you enable
the smart object plugin,
if you go to your blackboard,
there's another kind of blackboard key that gets added,
which is this smart object claim handle.
This relates to this reservation system
that we were talking about.
It's basically the idea that an agent
can decide ahead of time,
I am going to seek out a smart object.
So that's obviously using this smart object subsystem
and accessing these collections that we've talked about.
I'm gonna find a smart object that I want to use
if there is one available.
And then the point that I've decided
I'm going to use it,
I'm going to reserve it so no one else can take it.
Then I'm gonna move to it
and then do what other interaction it defines.
So most of that is kind of done
through this getting started or the quick start,
but the kind of thing that it doesn't particularly
emphasize is the meaning of this reservation.
So I thought I would just kind of demonstrate
that a little bit.
What I've done here is if we just look
at each of these actors,
I've just added this kind of cube above each of them.
And you'll see that when a smart object actually changes,
so on our smart object component,
we've just hooked up to an event to basically say that,
hey, when our smart object has been claimed
or when it's been released, set the material on this cube.
So essentially this cube will denote to us
when someone has kind of claimed this smart object
when they said, hey, I'm the one who's gonna use this.
And when it's no longer being used,
it's kind of the material has changed back.
And the whole idea here is that we have three objects
that can be interacted with
before people who want to do the interacting.
All of these use the same behavior tree.
So they're trying to access the same data.
And you can see here that it's most obvious
right at the beginning,
you'll see three of the agents
will just instantly run to these objects.
That's because the first thing they've done
is looked for an object to utilize
and they've reserved it and then they move over to it
and then do the interaction.
The interaction is just this jump.
And then the fourth agent,
because there's nothing available,
they just don't do anything.
They just sit still until whichever agent
got to its thing first and finished the interaction
instantly at that point it's released
and that fourth agent will then move
to that first available thing to actually interact with it.
So we see instantly it flickers green
and then go red again,
because as soon as it's available,
if there was an agent waiting,
it will then get reserved.
So this just kind of demonstrates
that reservation functionality
a little bit more comprehensively.
So that's smart objects.
Obviously with all of these plugins,
there's a lot more detail we can go into.
This is kind of more just to act as a little bit
of an introduction to say what it's there to achieve
and kind of roughly how you can interact with it,
but absolutely kind of dig into that more
in your own time.
So next up is state trees.
State trees is essentially a blend of behavior trees
and state machines.
So if you might be familiar with state machines already,
we talked about them a little bit
in the second session if you've seen that,
because state machines are used quite a lot
in animation blueprints.
State machines, if you're not familiar with them,
are essentially the idea that a particular state
can be represented by a kind of node or data.
And there are rules that govern how we can transition
from one state to others.
So giving animation as an example,
you could be in your idle state
and then from that idle state, hypothetically,
we could transition into our jump state
or our running state based on different rules.
If we're jumping, then we transition to our jump state.
If we're running, then we transition to our running state.
If we're kind of moving and jumping,
then certain rules will define
that jumping is higher priority
and therefore we still transition to our jumping state
even though we are both moving and jumping.
So obviously there is also this idea
that it's not just one or the other.
Sometimes you have a competition,
you need to think about priorities
or you need to think about extra rules
to govern which of these two states
should we transition to into
even if hypothetically both of them are possible.
So that's the idea of state machines.
And obviously even within that,
you have this idea of the idea
that when you are in a state,
you can transition possibly back
or perhaps a state can only transition in one direction.
These are typical concepts for state machines.
It's not an unreal unique thing,
but then behavior tree is also not an unreal unique thing,
but state tree kind of brings both of these things together.
It brings over the functionality of state machines.
So our AI logic,
if we think about our behavior tree,
we can basically make it a little bit more like a web
so that we can transition
if we were to kind of look at a behavior tree
is this very kind of top-down hierarchy
where we can't go from a fine smart object to wait
if we wanted to,
we have to kind of obey the rules of the existing system.
We have to structure our things
so we can negotiate between these things.
Whereas state tree gives us more of the ability
to go from each of our states
and transition to any other state
based on conditions that we kind of specify.
So it's less of this pure top-down flow.
At the same time though,
a state tree is also hierarchical.
So what that means is it exists in a hierarchical tree,
meaning you can technically be in multiple states at once.
It's a little bit similar to our behavior tree,
the way that when I'm in my fine smart objects task,
I am technically within, in an abstract sense,
I'm within this branch of the tree
and therefore I'm in sequence
and therefore I'm in this selector,
but it's a little bit more explicit
and it gives us the capability
to actually build in behavior to that hierarchy.
So yeah, like I said,
the states are arranged in a tree structure.
The selection usually starts at the root
and the state trees require a schema to be selected
which is essentially how do we typically expect
this state tree to be used?
Like what is our typical context for this to be used?
That might be on, it's part of a state tree component
so we expect it to be on an actor.
It might be a camera directed state tree
if you're using a state tree to govern, you know,
cameras in your game or in your cinematics.
Like with a few of these different plugins,
this isn't purely for AI.
You can use state trees for other things.
I think in a lot of the examples,
they use state trees for animations.
Obviously the parallels with state machines
from animation being very obvious.
So you could use state trees to govern things like,
well, anything that has state really.
So if you had, I think the typical example they give
is like a chest that is, once you open it,
it plays animation to be in the open state.
You can imagine various uses for these outside of AI,
but AI is one of the uses for this.
So yes, so within a state tree,
this is what it actually looks like.
Again, we have this,
you can see this tree structure already emerging.
So just to kind of talk about this a little bit,
we've got the root here.
This is a kind of first selected state.
This is a little bit like the root of our behavior tree
as our entry point.
And then we have these kind of sub nodes.
So each of these are reacting,
well, the state here that is called reacting state
is actually called a selector state.
This refers to a state that has child states within it.
So the kind of important thing to be aware of with this,
and it can be particularly confusing
if you're trying to debug your state tree a little bit
and you kind of maybe disable some of those states,
it can lead to behavior
that might not necessarily expect unless you know this,
is that as soon as you put a state
within another state,
that state becomes what's called a selector state.
And that means that this state's reacting
can never be selected directly.
You can't really be in the reacting state itself.
All you can ever do once you have children
is be in one of the child states.
And that inherently implies
that you are both in the reacting state
and the flee state or handle obstacle state
or hit state in this situation.
So once a state has children,
you can never choose specifically to be in that state.
You can only be in one of its children,
but by being in one of its children,
it inherently implies that you are also in that state,
bringing that kind of, again, that hierarchical flow.
So as soon as you're in the flee state,
you are also inherently part of the root,
part of the reacting state.
If you're within the smart object state here,
well, if you're in the reach state,
you are inherently part of the smart objects,
selector state, part of the idling selector state,
and part of the root.
And then, yeah, if we have,
we have this idea of the kind of state enter condition,
which essentially refers to a list of conditions
that determine whether or not this state can be selected.
So if our state here can't be chosen
based on certain logic that we can specify,
again, this whole idea that as with the state machines,
we can only transition into this state
based on certain conditions.
And then we actually have the task,
which is the things that this state performs.
So this is actually the kind of,
when we're in the state, what do we actually do?
What does this state actually mean?
And then last of all,
we have this concept of transitions,
which is our ability to move from one state to another
based on certain rules.
We'll actually come to that in a little bit,
but that can be kind of this state ending
when a certain task completes
or based on certain queries that we might be making
during the kind of running of that state.
So the kind of concepts
that are important to bear in mind,
states themselves, I feel like I'm gonna say state
like a hundred times whilst I'm talking about this,
but yeah, it's the state that has the conditions
for when this, it can be entered.
It will contain evaluators, tasks, and transitions.
So that is really what a state is.
Evaluators, we'll talk about in a little bit.
Tasks, we'll kind of talk about in a little bit,
but all of these things really,
we'll talk about in a little bit,
but it's the state itself kind of groups
all of these things together.
That's what kind of what a state is.
It's a grouping of evaluators, tasks, and transitions.
Selecting a state will activate all of the states
from the root to the leaf.
So this is what we're talking about,
this hierarchical nature.
So if I'm in the flea state,
then automatically the reacting and root state
are all active because it's inherently implied
I'm in all of these states.
And that kind of means that any additional tasks
or any additional functionality
that's introduced with each of these states
is inherently brought in.
If we have any ticks going on in the reacting state,
whilst I'm in the flea state,
those reacting state ticks would still be running
because I am always in the reacting state
when I'm in the flea state.
Data exposed by any state will be available
to other states further down the tree.
So if we have, again,
we'll talk about evaluators and parameters in a little bit,
but if we have evaluators of parameters
as part of the reacting state,
all of those will be available to any of the child states.
Yeah, all tasks are executed for all active states.
So I've kind of already mentioned that,
that when we're in the flea state,
any tasks that we have on the reacting selector state
would also be running.
And a state can contain multiple tasks
that are all running concurrently
for as long as the state remains active.
So that's kind of what tasks really mean.
It gives us this ability to,
whereas our behavior tree can only really be
in any one node at a time,
clearly from what we've talked about so far,
state trees are a lot more parallel.
They can have multiple tasks,
not just within a single state,
but you might have tasks within the parent states
that are also executing simultaneously.
So it's a lot more of this kind of parallel nature.
A task, I feel like we've kind of already talked
about that a little bit now,
so it's probably obvious,
but tasks similar to how tasks work in behavior tree,
they are the thing that,
this is the kind of logic, the doing stuff.
The difference here being that whilst in the behavior tree
you would typically end,
your leaf node is typically gonna be a task
and you're gonna be in one of those at any given time
in the context of state tree,
tasks can be running,
you can have many tasks running simultaneously.
The task is not the kind of the node to be in.
The node is really our state
and tasks can also provide output,
which can then be used by other parts
of the behavior tree, of the state tree, sorry.
So a task can return a value
which we could plug into a parameter.
So we could be running some kind of like,
find a nearest enemy in our reacting state.
The task could be feeding that into a parameter
and then that parameter is provided to our flee state
so that our flee can flee from the nearest enemy.
And I'm just coming up with a situation here,
but that's essentially how that could hypothetically work,
that our tasks within our reacting state
could provide information that we bind to parameters
and those parameters can be utilized
by any of the elements
beneath that reacting state in the tree.
Yeah, common outputs might be selecting of a target,
like I said, finding the kind of nearest enemy
or finding the nearest target
that you want to attack or something like that.
Another thing might be that, you know,
you might play an animation in the task.
You can imagine all the kinds of different things
that you might need to do in a behavior tree task,
which you could also do in a state tree task,
but it's also the idea that they can make data available
to the rest of the tree
and also that they can be running concurrently.
And also when a task completes, it triggers a transition,
which can result in the selection of the new state
if you kind of specified that.
There's also this idea of global tasks,
which is worth mentioning,
which is essentially tasks that exist
out of particular states
and kind of exist at the root level of the tree itself
so they're always running as long as the tree is running.
I'll actually kind of just quickly show that.
We've got a state tree here,
if I jump into our state tree example.
Again, there is a state tree example with this project,
so you can kind of take a look at this,
but you can see we've got, here's our tree.
It's a lot simpler,
but you can see we've also got the ability.
This is the kind of,
whilst we're talking about individual states here,
we can define things that are going on in these states.
We can define tasks for this state,
but also here we have the asset details
for the state tree itself,
and you can see the state tree itself,
we can expose kind of global parameters.
We can expose global evaluators.
Again, we don't know what each of those things means
at the moment,
but there is this kind of global set of data,
and we have global tasks,
which are tasks that will be running
as long as this state tree is running in any context,
regardless of what state we're in.
And again, yeah,
they can make permanent data available
for the rest of our logic for our tree,
for selecting different states.
Then we have transitions.
So transitions, similar to state trees,
to state machines, sorry.
This is basically the rules that would govern
when we transition from one state to another.
And they can contain trigger conditions
that need to be met before the transition triggers.
So that could be, in the example you'll see in a minute,
we've got a transition that will only occur
when your health has reached zero,
therefore we should transition into the dead state,
or maybe it's that your ammo is full,
and therefore we don't need to go be
in the search for ammo state anymore,
or something like this.
Yeah, some transitions are monitored at intervals,
whilst others are only executed when state's complete.
So as we kind of mentioned here,
we've got the idea of tasks
that can trigger transitions,
but also we can check these things on an interval.
So for something like death, we could either,
well, it probably makes sense to kind of check
that on a frequency to be like, you know,
every frame or every couple of seconds,
check whether or not our health is zero,
and then transition into the dead state.
And then the completion of the transition triggers.
Yeah, yeah.
So essentially, the completion of transitions
trigger the state where the task
that is completed is located.
So the transition completes within the,
at the point where the task that is completing
that transition is located.
And then, yeah, the other thing to mention
is we've talked about the idea of like,
transitions that are triggered when states complete,
or tasks complete, and we've also talked about the idea
of transitions that occur on events,
such as tick, such as on a frequency.
It's worth mentioning that the ones that are tick
and event-based are handled before completion transitions,
so that if they technically happen within the same moment,
we have the ability to execute the event,
the ones that are responding to events first.
And then last of all, like I said,
we have this idea of evaluators and parameters.
Essentially, both of these, these are distinct notions,
but they achieve the same result,
which is exposing data to the rest of our state tree.
So parameters are essentially variables
that can be utilized throughout the state tree.
Parameters can either exist globally
within the whole state tree,
or they can exist within states.
So again, if we just come back to our image here,
we can have, our reacting could have parameters within it,
which are then inherently exposed to flee,
handle obstacle, and hit,
or our entire state tree could have parameters in it,
which every state can either write into
through various tasks or read from
for various transition logic or whatever.
Evaluators are similar,
but where parameters are the data that is written into,
evaluators are essentially functions that we can run
to go and grab data as and when we want it.
So we've got an example of an evaluator
in the little example that we've got,
which is essentially just to try and find
an appropriate spline nearby.
But yeah, essentially they're scriptable queries
that let us kind of get data
in a way that isn't just relying on data
being written into by other parts of the state tree.
And the other thing that's worth mentioning is if we,
I'll actually just quickly jump into the example
to kind of show this.
So this is what a state tree looks like.
Like I said, we've got our own example level.
So if you have the project downloaded,
you'll be able to open this up.
Worth mentioning as well that state tree
is behind a plugin,
but I think this is a plugin that is enabled by default,
but if not, do just check that it's enabled.
So again, this will be enabled in this project,
but if you're doing this in your own gameplay,
state tree and state tree,
I think both of these come enabled by default,
but I might be mistaken about that.
But either way, so we've got this example level set up.
This again is if you went to the state tree Quickstart,
then this is going to be a very, very similar implementation.
We're going to achieve the same goal.
The only thing that I would say is
some of the documentation on the Quickstart
is slightly out of date
or certain bits of data have kind of moved around
or changed names slightly.
So if you have any confusion or struggles
whilst you're implementing that
and you are following the documentation,
maybe just look at this as an example
for what might have been done incorrectly.
So what we've got is essentially a state tree
that is achieving some sort of AI.
And in this case, it's going to be a kind of target
that's going to move around the spline
and is going to respond to basically when it's dead,
it's going to kind of transition into a dead state.
So as soon as I hit play,
you'll see I've just got this target
that kind of loops around on a spline
and it will kind of like just repeatedly loop.
I've also got like a little cursor
in the middle of the screen.
This isn't to do with the state tree,
but this is just purely
so I can actually see what I'm doing.
So what happens is when I click,
I'm doing a ray trace
for whether or not it's an enemy object.
And if it's the enemy object,
I'm going to damage that enemy.
And when I shoot my enemy three times,
then it's going to transition into our dead state
and it's going to kind of show some debugging behavior
just to kind of represent that.
So if I click on the enemy one time,
two times, three times, now it's dead.
And you can see we get this little debug
to say actor destroyed, and then it's gone.
And that is all utilizing the state tree.
So one thing that kind of, like I said,
this acts as a kind of replacement to behavior trees.
But one of the things that's kind of really nice
about the behavior tree is how easy it is to debug.
And one of the things you might notice
whilst we're playing is there isn't,
doesn't seem to be like an innate way.
There doesn't seem to be quite that same plugin
and play logic for debugging
what's currently going on in your state tree.
If I were to kind of quickly play this,
you see I'm not getting this kind of,
I don't have that same thing that I do
with our behavior tree where I've got those kind
of chevrons where I can drop down
and choose which behavior tree I'm listening to
and then see a runtime representation of what's going on.
Or it can seem that way initially.
Actually, there is a debugger.
It's not kind of put right to the front
and it's not quite as instantaneously available,
but it is there.
And it's essentially an implementation of what,
of a more of kind of a whole subset
of Unreal debugging functionality,
which is called the visual logger.
The visual logger is essentially a tool
that can record state about your world
and then gives you the ability to kind of,
and it can write, it doesn't just log data,
but it logs data in a kind of visual way.
So you could, for example, log down the positions of things
and you could actually see that data visualized
in your level.
And the other thing about the visual logger
that's very cool is you kind of record your world state
and you can actually scrub back through that state
in a timeline to kind of track where
and when things changed and really visualize these things
in a way that isn't always baked into that like,
oh, I've just missed it this frame
and now it's gone forever kind of thing.
I have to kind of replicate it
and hopefully put a break point.
It's done in this kind of saved a timeline scrubable way,
which is very nice.
So if you're familiar with the visual logger,
then this is gonna look very similar.
You'll be kind of quite familiar with this,
but if you just, once you have the state tree open,
so state trees are represented in their own assets,
which is in the example is just here,
we have the state tree asset.
If you just go to, I think it's window and then debugger
that opens the state tree debugger.
And if you are just playing,
this has actually got a previous recording in there,
but if I just went to,
if I just snap this to the side of my screen
and then played with that debugger window open,
you would see it's actually,
you can see it recording data.
And then I'm just gonna do the shooting
and now my actor is destroyed.
And you can see it's clearly responded to that
and it stopped recording
because the whole state tree is now closed off.
So I'll just stop the recording because I can,
but we can now,
so whilst we're actually playing,
you'll see whilst the state tree is running,
you do actually have a live representation
of what's going on.
You can see this is actually showing me
I'm in my moving spline state.
And if I take enough damage,
then it transitions into the dead state.
You can see all of this stuff happening.
But as well as that,
if I stop that recording and I'm scrubbing through it,
you can see I have this now saved representation
of all the things that went on.
And again, some of this will be familiar
from the, if you've used the visual logger before,
but you can actually see bits of information
that are getting debugged here
about like what state we're in,
what transitions were being queried
and all of this information.
So it's kind of a lot of very, very helpful information.
And yes, that's kind of like an implementation
of the visual logger.
So just worth bearing in mind
that when you're working with state tree,
it's not immediately obvious that you can debug it,
but you can, and it's very, very powerful.
Yeah, and I suppose if you want to go
into more information
about this kind of particular implementation,
again, this is essentially just a re-implementation
of the quick start.
So you can kind of follow up there.
I'm not gonna go into too much more detail about this,
but you can look at the project
and look at the documentation.
Next up, we have mass entity.
This is a little bit like the other plugins,
isn't strictly related to AI,
but it definitely has relevance.
So if you've watched some of the previous presentations,
then you might recall all the way back
in probably the first presentation,
we talked about the idea of actors and components.
And what I mentioned then
is this is not entity component system architecture.
Actors and components is more about the idea
of modular reusable functionality
that you can kind of slot into an entity.
Mass entity is entity component system architecture.
So mass entity is Unreal's implementation of ECS.
So if you're familiar with ECS,
this will already be very, very familiar to you.
We're just going to kind of go a little bit
through what Unreal's implementation
of those things looks like.
But if you're not familiar with ECS and why it exists,
to kind of very, very briefly summarize that,
essentially when you're working in software,
particularly in object oriented software,
there are a lot of things that we do as programmers
that kind of make sense to us because we're human
and we want to work with things in a way
that makes sense to human beings.
That's very good for readability.
It's very good for maintainability.
But what it's not always good for
is the computer's actual performance.
Just taking, for an example,
a standard like enemy structure that you might have,
you might have an enemy class
and that enemy has a location, it has health,
it has a mesh, it has a texture.
And then maybe you make a child class of that
that is like winged flying enemy
and it's got all these extra functions
for take flight or land
and it brings in some additional meshes
and stuff like that.
And this is obviously a kind of slightly peculiar hierarchy
that I've just constructed in my head,
but you can imagine that we do these kinds of things.
And so it makes a lot of sense
to us as software engineers to have this structure
because you can see that every winged enemy is an enemy
and all these things are coupled together.
The difficulty is that when you're working
in something like a game engine,
very commonly the game engine is working
with lots of these things simultaneously.
So the physics system might be iterating
through all of the entities in your world
to grab their collision data.
And then when one of your characters moves,
then we need to query all of that collision data
to establish, am I gonna hit something?
Just as a kind of small example.
So if we have all of our data
structured together in this way,
essentially when we create that enemy
or that winged enemy,
we're going to hopefully block out a big chunk of memory
that represents that enemy
and that's gonna have its location in it.
So that's a vector three,
so that's gonna be what,
like at least 96,
so that's 96 bytes.
And then we've got like our health,
that's gonna be a float,
that's gonna be at least four bytes.
Sorry, I said 96 bits, so 12 bytes.
And then you've got your health,
which is gonna be another four bytes,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
When our physics system is now trying to gather
all of that data to get together,
all the physics system really cares about
is our collision geometry.
And there's all this fluff in the way, right?
It's suddenly having to,
it's technically when it's gathering up all our enemies,
it's getting all of those enemies' health,
all of those enemies' positions,
all of the extra bits of data that enemy has,
its damage, what weapon it has equipped
and all this kind of stuff.
If you're familiar with the way
that CPUs are structured,
you would be familiar with the idea
that we have this concept of caches.
We have an L1 cache, an L2 cache, L3 cache,
sometimes L4 cache,
and then we go up to random access memory
to our computer's RAM.
So, and each of these caches and RAM
perform at different speeds.
So for the best performance,
essentially what our computer would like,
would be best for the CPU performance
is to be always getting data from my L1 cache.
Our L1 cache is our smallest,
but most high performance section of memory.
Whenever we try and get data
that is not in our L1 cache,
it will kind of look up to our L2 cache
to see if it's there,
and if it's there, then fine,
that's gonna be a little bit slower, but that's okay.
And so on and so forth.
So if it's not in our L2 cache,
it'll look through our L3 cache,
and eventually it ends up at RAM.
And each of these steps,
getting data from our L2 cache,
getting data from our L3 cache,
getting data from our RAM
is gonna be exponentially more expensive
in terms of time cost,
in terms of actual CPU cycles,
so the time it takes to literally get that memory
from that place to our CPU for operating on.
Whenever our CPU does that,
whenever our CPU gets data,
what it will do is essentially get something
called a cache line.
It doesn't just get the data it's asking for.
It typically gets a chunk of data
to either side of that memory
because it's gathering that on a bus.
That bus is a particular size.
It might as well gather that much memory.
And then if the next bit of data it reads
happens to be within that same cache line,
that's basically a free read.
That memory is already available to you.
It's like whenever our computer is,
the term bus is quite applicable here,
it's whenever our computer is going out to get memory,
it's loading all of that memory onto a bus,
and anything that's already on that bus
is already there, right?
So the more that we can compact our data
in a particular way,
the more when we're doing certain bits of functionality,
if we can kind of try and align that data
so that we know whatever data we're gonna need next
is next to that data,
it vastly increases the chance
that we'll be caught in the same cache line
and certainly increases the chance
that it's gonna be part of the same,
at least in the L2 cache, at least in the L3 cache,
that all of the most relevant data
is gonna be grouped together
and all of the bits of the data that aren't relevant
are gonna be kind of like not considered.
That's essentially the problem
that ECS architecture is there to solve.
It's a way of grouping only the bits of relevant data in,
well, that's what our component is,
and then we have the NC
that kind of groups these components together
and the systems that work with the components.
And so the system only cares
about the isolated bits of data.
We can ram all of these
compacted as possible bits of data together,
and therefore the system can be as performant as possible.
So that was quite a lot of,
you know, jargon and words.
And for anyone who's kind of more an expert
on CPUs and ECS architecture,
I may have, you know, made some mistakes there,
but that's broadly the problem it's trying to achieve.
So that's the reason that you,
essentially ECS architecture
is something that you may consider using
when you have highly performant bits of functionality
that you need, where you need lots of data
and you need to do something with that data.
So Boyd's implementations might be an example,
crowds, traffic.
So yeah, anything where you're doing a lot of something
and you can kind of boil that something down
into kind of not exactly atomic,
but small bits of data that are highly reusable,
that might be something where you might want
to consider ECS architecture.
And mass entity is essentially
Unreal's implementation of ECS.
So then basically what we have
is just a mapping of terms, right?
If you're familiar with ECS,
then fragment is essentially our component.
It represents an atomic piece of data
used in the calculations.
So examples of this might be a transform or a velocity.
And again, these fragments are data only.
They aren't part of the point of ECS architecture
is you are not marrying up,
unlike typical object-orientated functionality
where you marry up,
a lot of the time you marry up data with functionality.
Fragments are there only to provide the data,
only to provide the memory.
Fragments also can't be created in blueprint,
which is something to bear in mind.
A lot of this is kind of more of a C plus plus thing.
Then we have entities,
which the term is the same,
and this is maps to our entity and our ECS architecture.
And essentially entities
represent collections of fragments.
So these kind of group things,
group these fragments together.
So when our,
yeah, they kind of group our fragments together
in a possibly unique way.
So they contain a unique identifier
that could be used for lookups
so that we kind of know which entity
we're talking about
when we're talking about particular archetypes.
And yeah, creating an entity is similar to class instancing,
but the way entities actually are defined
is really all an entity kind of needs to know about
other than the individual instances of that entity.
Part of the entity's definition
is what fragments it's made up of.
And an entity's composition
is very relevant to the rest of the system
because we're gonna get into this in a moment,
this concept of archetypes,
which are essentially groups
and see the same composition together.
Compositions of entities can be changed at runtime
so that they can kind of gain fragments.
If that's required.
But yeah, essentially entities exist to group
sets of fragments together
for whatever this entity kind of requires
and can also be uniquely looked up.
They have an entity ID
to kind of pair a particular fragment up
with what entity is this for.
Similar to fragments, these are data only,
so they shouldn't have any kind of functions in them.
It is pure data.
So then we have archetypes,
which don't necessarily,
they certainly don't have a marry up
to any of the EC or S,
but archetypes are essentially collections of entities
with identical composition.
And it's these archetypes that are utilized
when our processes, which is our S, our system,
when our systems try to work with things,
they actually, what they will query for
is archetypes for all entities
that have the same composition.
Yeah, so an archetype is in a way
that an entity of a particular composition
and an archetype is composed of different types
of fragments in a specific configuration.
So for an example of an archetype might be this,
an archetype is going to be,
our archetype is transform velocity,
and therefore it's going to contain an array
of all the entities that have a composition
that is a transform fragment
and a velocity vector fragment.
And then we're going to have this array of entities here.
We've got our entity ID here.
So, you know, zero, one or two or whatever.
And then here is the velocity for each,
is the velocity fragment for entity zero.
Here's our transform fragment for entity zero
and so on and so forth for entity one,
entity two, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So you can see how these things kind of couple together.
Our archetype is all of the entities
of the same composition,
composition here being entities
that have only a transform fragment
and only a transform and velocity fragment.
And then we'll contain them in an array.
And then these things are kind of like paired up.
So the ID is paired up with its transform
and its velocity.
So processes is the S of our ECS architecture, our systems.
And these are essentially the things
where entity and fragment are data only.
Processor is the thing that actually does
the functionality.
And the kind of one of the key concepts about processes
is they are stateless.
So they are really just there to do things
to the fragments and entity which provide the data.
And essentially, as we were kind of already mentioned,
oh no, actually I can display that in the next segment,
but they use entity queries to specify
what kind of archetypes they're looking for,
for what kind of fragments they need.
And then they get this NC query will return an archetype
which contains all the relevant fragments
for all the operations that this system would need to do.
So a system might be something
like a traffic management system.
And therefore it only needs to know the locations
and velocities of all of the traffic.
And therefore it makes a query saying,
I need an archetype that is anything
that has a transform and velocity.
And then the query will return that archetype
with all the relevant entities.
And then the traffic system just performs
whatever operations it needs to on those entities,
just knowing that all I care about
is the location and the velocity.
And I add the velocity to the transform
or whatever the system is gonna do.
An example of this could be the mass movement processes.
So you can just look at that in the C++.
So again, kind of just a visual representation
of what I was talking about.
The processor says, I need,
it uses an NC query for a particular archetype
and the archetype it's searching for
is anything with a transform and velocity.
We filter the archetype to essentially find
the relevant archetype.
And then that's gonna return this array of entity,
of fragments essentially to the processor for working with
and that's gonna return an array of the transform
and velocity arrays for the person to work with.
Then the last thing that is worth mentioning
is there are a couple of special types of fragments.
So the examples we've given so far
is things like transforms, velocity, vectors,
you can kind of imagine,
but there are these extra special kind of fragment types,
which are worth mentioning.
So we have tag fragments,
which is a little bit like,
somewhat similar to gameplay tags.
You're familiar with that concept.
And the tag is a fragment which contains no data itself.
It is purely the presence or absence of a tag
that is used to represent the thing.
So if you could imagine something that might be like
an is visible flag,
all we need to do is have a tag
that is like the visible tag.
If that visible tag is present, then it is visible.
If that fragment doesn't exist at all,
then we can perceive it as not visible.
And so therefore it doesn't need any extra data.
It just needs to exist or not exist
to kind of demark that particular data about the entity.
It's worth mentioning that when we're adding these tags,
this is part of the entity's composition.
So when we said about archetypes,
grouping together all entities of the same composition,
they would also group together.
Tags would be taken into account in this.
So they would be grouped under a separate archetype.
If we had 10 entities with a transform and a velocity,
and we had one entity with a transform velocity and a tag,
then those would be in separate archetypes.
And then we have chunk fragments.
Chunk fragments aren't directly associated with an entity,
unlike most fragments.
They are associated with a chunk.
And what the archetype will do is group these chunks
together for separate processing.
So the kind of most obvious place
that this would be relevant is something like LODs.
So the archetype will kind of sub-organize
based on particular chunks.
And one of those chunk data might be the various LODs.
And so it's not associated with the entity itself,
it's associated with the chunk.
And therefore the archetype might have
a few different chunk fragments within it
that kind of define the different levels of detail
and these things get operated on in slightly different ways.
And again, this chunk fragment represents
part of an entity's composition.
So the entities that kind of do technically have
that chunk fragment associated with them
would have a different composition
and therefore would be grouped under a different archetype.
So that's the kind of everything
to talk about in mass density.
A lot of that is just mapping of terms
and these kind of special extra little bits
of data available to you.
There isn't actually an example
for mass density implementation,
but I will talk about something in a bit
that is kind of quite relevant
if you're interested in looking into this more.
But the last plugin to talk about is the zone graph.
So zone graph is, again, another plugin.
It won't be enabled by default.
So if you just go into your plugin section,
you can kind of look at that.
It is enabled in the example project
because there is an example of this one.
But essentially zone graph is
a kind of lightweight navigation system
for navigating around typically large spaces
that might feature streaming in and streaming out.
It allows pathfinding for portions of the world
that may even be not streamed into.
The really obvious examples is things like,
again, traffic systems.
I was already talking about traffic systems
with the mass entity system,
but traffic systems or pavements or trade networks
if you're doing something like a civilization game.
A lot of these things don't necessarily,
they have a concept of navigation,
but it's a lot more strict and rules bound.
It doesn't need the kind of free flowing navigation
of NavMesh, which can be a lot more expensive
because what NavMesh says is,
when we pick two points,
we define these large sections of space,
which can be freely negotiated around
and may at any point have obstructions.
And so you would need to negotiate around them
or areas of high cost.
And so we need to negotiate around those.
Instead, what the zone graph defines
is more explicit points.
We can kind of say,
oh, I transitioned from A to B,
and I know that I can only follow these particular lines.
And these lines might be lanes,
they may merge, they may branch in certain places,
but it's a lot more kind of point to point rules bound.
So the kind of navigation system
can be a lot more efficient.
It can be a lot more long distance.
You know, NavMesh, a consistent NavMesh
across like a 10 kilometer by 10 kilometer space
is going to be, you know,
a lot more costly to work out
how to get from one end of the island
to the other end of the island.
And for something like, you know,
a car where that car is only gonna stay to a road,
and there are only two roads on the whole island,
you can instantly see how this can afford to be
a lot more efficient.
And it can also be aware even of sections of that road
that don't need to be streamed in at the moment,
the zone graph system can still be aware
that those roads do exist, even if they are streamed out.
So the couple of bits of data
that are kind of relevant to zone graph to be aware of
is the zone shape data,
which essentially defines kind of our lanes,
our areas that are,
this is a little bit like our
NavMesh bounds volume, sorry,
reaching for the term there.
So this essentially defines our lanes.
We can set it up with a lane profile
to determine the number of lanes,
so any tags about it, what direction they go in,
why these lanes are.
A lot of this talks about traffic systems,
but you can obviously think about the same things
like paths through a wood,
if it's for, I don't know,
random adventurers in your RTS game,
or the same thing would apply for pavements or sidewalks,
depending on if you're American or English,
and the same kind of rules would apply.
Then we have our zone graph data,
which is roughly equivalent to our NavMesh data.
This is the kind of runtime thing
that is actually built out of our zone shapes,
and is the thing that is gonna be
our kind of centralized point of data
that is actually our total built up idea
of what is all the navigable space
based of our zone shapes.
And then we have our zone graph testing actor.
So this is something, this is a little bit like the,
there is an equivalent in NavMesh,
I think it's called the NavMesh testing actor,
which essentially visualizes a way
that we can get from one bit of our NavMesh to another,
what that would actually look like.
Zone graph testing actor does the same thing.
And then our zone graph annotation testing actor,
which essentially allows us to add a bunch of tests
about how we might be transitioning
between these different zones
and kind of adds in additional rules.
So just quickly looking at lane profiles, for example,
I've actually got, like I said, a little setup here.
So if we go to our zone graph example,
this again, another implementation
of the zone graph quick start,
but you can see we've defined our various zone graphs
here, we, and in this I've got,
sorry, if I actually just choose my zone graph here,
you can see we've essentially defined
these kind of, these curved shapes.
And we can see we've got these two different lanes
that are going in different directions.
That is reliant on,
and you can say we've got a lane profile selected here,
which is, I've defined this space.
How should we actually lay out the lanes within this space?
In this sense, it's a two-way traffic,
which I think is the Unreal default.
We can add in some debugging data,
which is like, what kind of shape should it be?
What colors should it represent in?
If we go to our edit and plugins,
sorry, edit project settings,
you can see we can define additional lane profiles.
Sorry, if I go to zone graph,
I now suddenly can't find my zone graph.
Engine zone graph, here we go.
Yeah, so we've got our list of lane profiles here.
So the default that I think zone graph
always comes in with is two-way traffic,
but obviously if you need something more like a,
you know, a four-lane motorway
or something that is only one directional
or something like that,
you can define additional lane profiles here.
And then you can choose those lane profiles
for your different zone shapes.
This just has an example of like what,
you know, a random might look like.
We've got things for like a crossing.
So again, this is particularly more applicable
for something like a traffic system where, you know,
you're only allowed to transition
from one lane to another lane.
And when you have different shapes,
how would you actually transition
between those different things?
So this is all demonstrated in this project,
but it's also gone into in more detail
in the Unreal documentation.
So absolutely look up the quick start guide
for kind of reference documentation
for a step-to-step guide.
So I think that is everything to talk about.
Yeah, the one thing that I wanted to mention,
like I said, we didn't have an example implementation
for a mass entity,
but smart objects, state tree, mass entity, and zone graph
are all featured quite heavily in Epic City Sample,
which they did for Matrix Awakens.
So if you want to see a kind of more comprehensive
representation of each of these plugins
and how you might utilize them,
absolutely go check that out.
There is documentation about it that you can go to,
but there's also, if you just look up the City Sample
on FAB or in the Epic Launcher, which will take you to FAB,
you can find the City Sample there.
I've actually just opened that tab in my browser,
haven't I?
So yeah, if you kind of want a more detailed look
over some of these plugins and how they work,
I would thoroughly encourage you
to go check out the City Sample.
They've got lots of documentation on it.
Obviously you can download the project itself
and actually just go into how all of that stuff
has been implemented.
And that about wraps it up.
The only thing to mention,
as we've done with the previous two slides,
is just mentioning about the various resources
available to you.
We've obviously got the documentation.
I just talked about some of the documentation
for the project-specific stuff.
We've got the Unreal Engine YouTube.
We have Twitch streams.
We have the UDN for Unreal licensees.
For anyone who's not an Epic licensee,
we've got the AnswerHub,
which is a very, very active community.
I think Epic recently announced
that they are actually going to start introducing
a special category of posts on AnswerHub,
which is going to be pulling answered,
solved problems from the UDN,
the kind of like licensee-specific area of the forums.
And they're going to be pulling high traffic,
important answers into AnswerHub
to expose some of the kind of dev secrets
to the rest of the community.
So that's a really cool thing that they've started doing.
And then last of all, we've got the Unreal Engine community
for a whole host of community-based tutorials
and documents.
Just worth mentioning that obviously sometimes
some of that stuff is a little bit out of date.
So it's not unlike the Unreal documentation,
which is generally kept up to date
with the latest versions of the engine.
That's not always the most optimal solutions,
not always completely in date,
but still a very, very potent resource.
So that about wraps us up after, I think,
probably close to three to four hours of material.
Hopefully it's been useful to you.
And like I said, with a lot of this stuff,
it's worth looking further, look up the documentation,
look at some of these example projects.
And thanks very much.
Hope this has been useful to you.